we're gonna begin with this police in
Louisiana or releasing new details about
the man accused of killing a popular
Baton Rouge civil rights activists 38
year old Ron Bell was arrested yesterday
on a charge of murdering Sadie Roberts
Joseph now police say that Bell was her
tenant her body was found in her car
outside a vacant home last week Errol
Barnett is outside the museum that she
founded in Baton Rouge
Errol a lot of people are glad there's
been an arrest in this case what led
police to to bail
well good morning Gail two things both
circumstantial and physical evidence
police say that Bell owed the woman
known as Sadie rent money the police
report shows that he admitted to being
in the area where her vehicle was found
but the real breakthrough here the
physical evidence his DNA found on her
body hundreds gathered in a Louisiana
heat Tuesday at the African American
History Museum
Sadie Roberts have founded nearly two
decades ago folks coming together to
celebrate her life and a breakthrough in
the case
Baton Rouge Police credited detectives
and the community in helping find Robert
Joseph's accused killer a tenant in one
of her rental homes
police say Ron Jermaine Bell suffocated
the 75 year old on Friday placing her
body in the trunk of her own car we
believe that he was behind several
months on his rent we believe around
$1,200 was old according to the East
Baton Rouge District Attorney bail was
previously arrested accused of raping an
8-year old girl in 2004 he pleaded
guilty to sexual battery and served
seven years in prison he was not on
probation or parole but was under
indefinite supervision as a sex offender
what happens next to this suspect well
we still have a lot of work to do we're
gonna continue following up on a more
investigative leads trying to put the
pieces to the puzzle
Roberts Joseph's daughter is encouraging
everyone to move past
they're outraged what should people do
with that anger and that frustration
they're feeling right now for those who
were and are angry live a better life
give of yourself to your community to
make the holy
better friends and family say the woman
known as miss Sadie live on through the
many people she taught the mayor said
miss Sadie is a matriarch of the city
now police are still working to
determine a clear motive in all of this
but they do not believe this was a hate
crime and to really underscore the
sentiment that we felt here yesterday
Miss Roberts Joseph's niece told me that
her heart breaks and goes out for the
suspects family
Anthony Merrill thank you yeah that's a
that's the right sentiment she always
will be a matriarch Oh Baton Rouge yeah
and it's hard to hear that she died
under those circumstances by somebody it
seems she was right he'll be helping
given a chance to